avec notre partenaire google comme tous
les matins bonjour à tous bonjour
françois bayrou bonjour quand la gauche
va vers la droite et quand la droite va
vers l'extrême droite ça devient
difficile de rester au centre pas du
tout le
lorsque vous avez une certitude sur
l'avenir du pays c'est très facile de
les défendre alors c'est vrai connaît
dans un temps où il ya des dérives dans
tous les sens où plus personne ne s'y
retrouve et où on essaie d'obsédé le
pays autour de questions
je ne dis pas qu'elles ne sont pas
importantes mais ce n'est pas
l'essentiel de la vie quotidienne des
gens la vie quotidienne des gens c'est
la difficulté avec le travail la
difficulté avec les fins de mois la
difficulté avec l'école ça c'est la vie
quotidienne des gens vous faites partie
de ces français qui ont voté françois
hollande en 2012 et qui sont prêts à
soutenir alain juppé en 2017 en quoi
françois hollande vous at il le plus
déçu vous
beaucoup de choses françois hollande n'a
pas n'a jamais pris la dimension de la
fonction présidentielle pendant les
quatre années qui viennent de s'écouler
il a été non il faut être juste il a été
tout à fait à la hauteur lorsqu'il s'est
agi par exemple d'intervenir au mali
hilale a pris des décisions et c'était
bien qu'ils les prennent mais pour ce
qui est de la vie du pays des
orientations qu'on lui donne du cap
qu'il faut suivre il n'a jamais su se
définir clairement et définir avec les
français où l'on allait et il s'est
constamment comporté comme le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui
essaient de faire des accords et les
compromis entre les différents courants
du parti socialiste les plus les plus
éloignés de la réalité il n'a jamais su
trancher dans le vif et les français se
sentent très très bien je crois que
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est dans
la situation d'opinion qu'on connaît
vous soutenez alain juppé c'est la
solidarité du grand sud-ouest qui vous
unit ou c'est la peur de revoir nicolas
sarkozy dont il ya peut-être de ça il ya
peut-être du fait que nous venons
des mêmes régions que nous avons suivi
des parcours qui se ressemble un peu
dans les études dans dans l'enracinement
dans la dans une mairie dans une mairie
vous savez bordeaux était la première
ville de l'aquitaine peau était la
deuxième donc et aussi la peur de voir
nicolas sarkozy revenir prévient je
dirais pas moi j'en aucune peur en
aucune manière c'est la démocratie et la
démocratie impose que l'on descend de
ses idées et ses convictions et entre
alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy il ya un
an des options absolument différente
vous le voyez bien tous les jours
nicolas sarkozy a choisi de rechercher
le succès électoral par la division du
pays en obsédant les français sur le
l'origine sur les gones wallon sur
l'identité sur les ancêtres alain juppé
parle de nullité de débat politique ce
matin bleu je crois que le mot est juste
le le débat politiques désespérants où
l'on fait croire aux gens que c'est dans
l'origine
des êtres humains que se trouve leur
avenir eh bien je suis évidemment comme
beaucoup très très
en réserve ou une réticence par rapport
à ce choix dans la famille à nos
ancêtres les gaulois vous vous situez où
à non mais moi j'ai des sens être qu'ils
sont plutôt des wisigoths donc là parce
que au pied des pyrénées les béarnais il
ya comme ça une identité très forte mais
vous voyez bien ce que ça signifie ça
signifie que pour définir l'identité de
la france à condition qu'ils aient
besoin de le faire pour définir
l'identité de la france on ne regarde
pas vers l'avenir on regarde vers
l'origine et ça devient une obsession
vous vous n'êtes pas
membre du peuple français parce que vous
avez gardé le souvenir de vos origines
ses dunes c'est d'une stupidité crasse
et c'est surtout complètement
régressif il ya là les médecins dirait
une névrose 1 qui pensaient que nicolas
sarkozy n est moins un client qui touche
l d'origine dont nicolas sarkozy sait
très bien ce qu'il fait il cherche des
voies pour la primaire ah c'est vous
savez le jugement que je porte sur la
primaire qui est un jugement très très
positif ils cherchent des voies pour la
primaire il a compris une loi électorale
que donald trump a très bien compris aux
états unis qui est que c'est en disant
les choses les plus choquantes qu'on
fait des voix parce que ça excite et le
train de français je veux pas employer
les mots comme ça
il ya évidemment parallélisme mais vous
voyez bien ça excite ce que les gens en
temps ne de rancoeur de de colère
rentrée et il pense que c'est avec ces
sentiments là qu'il va gagner la
primaire donc c'est une démarche
électorale et je trouve que c'est une
démarche qui ne sert pas l'avenir du
pays vous soutenez alain juppé mais vous
n'irez pas voter à la primaire c'est un
demi soutien non pas du tout c'est un
soutien complet partout mes amis mais si
j'allais responsables politiques si
j'allais voter à la primaire ça veut
dire que à l'avance j'en accepterait le
résultat or il se trouve que
j'accepte tout je soutiens
vous pouvez soutenir alain jugé
qu'il soit vainqueur et ensuite y aller
non mais non ça serait invivable vous
comprenez bien donc quand vous êtes un
responsable politique alors après vous
si vous êtes un simple citoyen vous avez
votre liberté puisque comme vous savez
il n'y a pas en france de mandat
impératif mais le le choix qui le mia
est en effet de dire si alain juppé est
choisi par la primaire je le soutiendrai
je lui apporterai mon med et la sarkozie
joyal à vous il est si nicolas sarkozy
gagne je prendrai mes responsabilités
donc vous donc nous en parlerons
ensemble une candidature pourrait
réduire considérablement votre espace
politique emmanuel macron alors voulu
envoyer un direct du droit macron est le
candidat des forces de l'argent vous
voyez bien créé la zizanie un chez les
centristes mais jean christophe lagarde
le patron de l'udps et y lui a tendu la
main et vous avez dit tant que je serai
là il y aura pas dopé à sur le centre eh
bien c'est exactement c'est le le centre
est une famille politique qui a une
vision originale de l'avenir et qui a
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
notamment mis en cause la politique
économique qui a été suivie et qui donne
les résultats désastreux que l'on sait
aujourd'hui
or
l'inspirateur de la politique économique
pendant les deux premières années est le
responsable direct au ministère de
l'économie pendant les deux années
suivantes c'est monsieur macron et donc
vouloir ou accepter l'idée que monsieur
macron pourrait
proposer autre chose que ce qui a été
suivie pendant ces quatre années ce
serait faire preuve d'une naïveté
excessive et d'autre part quand vous
regardez la manière dont tous est
organisé vous voyez là un projet de
société qui ne correspond pas aux nôtres
je les dis parce que il était nécessaire
qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté
beaucoup de français sont déboussolés un
juppé hollande sarkozy le pen ils se
disent c'est ça l'avenir de la france
c'est ça l'avenir de la france je pense
que alain juppé propose
une attitude politique différente c'est
le seul qui ait pris de la distance à
l'égard des appareils de parti comme
vous le savez d'ailleurs on le les
appareils de parti de lui rendent bien
si j'arrive à suivre l'actualité que
vous décrivez tous les jours et donc il
a pris de la distance et c'est parce
qu'il a pris cette distance qu'il peut
proposer une démarche de rassemblement
ce qui pour moi est vital le modem fait
sa rentrée à guidel dans le morbihan ce
week-end dans le dernier baromètre paris
match vous êtes deuxième personnalité
préférée des français juste derrière
alain juppé mais sur qui vous appuyez si
vous êtes candidat à la présidentielle
c'est ce qu'on se donne tous vous avez
votre parti certes mais vous avez une
équipe soudée moins de troupes jean
lassalle qui vous était très fidèle fait
cavalier seul est ce que est ce qu'être
libre comme vous dites toujours c'est
d'être seul un peu aussi sûrement pas
parce que les enquêtes que vous venez de
citer c'est vous qui les avez signes
montrent que il y a un très fort soutien
dans l'opinion publique française à une
proposition politique
différente de celle des deux parties qui
exerce le pouvoir depuis
l'intérieur simplement votre enfant sur
le nombre de personnes qui peuvent le
l'équipe de soutien de de cette volonté
pour le pays elle et elle existe elle
est plus soudé qu'aucune autre équipe et
dans l'opinion publique ou parmi les
élus elle est forte simplement depuis si
longtemps
le centre a renoncé à exister de manière
indépendante indépendante mais il ne
demande qu'à renaître il faut comprendre
que partout dans le pays il ya des
responsables il ya des jeunes femmes des
jeunes hommes engagés qui se retrouvent
dans cette vision là et je dis ce centre
existera et il gouvernera la france le
jour où il acceptera d'être unis et
indépendants des bouleaux d'oublier non
il n'ya pas tant de boulot ça non il
n'ya pas tant de boulot que ça
aujourd'hui la plupart de ces
responsables se retrouvent autour d'un à
juppé ils reconnaissent là une
possibilité une compatibilité pour
changer la vie politique française et
ils sont prêts à le faire en tout état
de cause il ya de ja c'est une force
simplement c'est une force qui s'est pas
révélée depuis longtemps et bien s'il le
fallait on a révélé jacques chirac est
toujours hospitalisée vous avez été son
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement supérieur pendant deux
ans 95 à 97 vous avez tous un les
politiques une vie politique a été lié à
jacques chirac soit en opposition et
c'est plutôt votre cas soit en soutien
en alliance
vous êtes j'imagine quand même affecté
par ce qui lui arrive on sait très
émouvant vous voyez cet homme qui a été
une force qui va comme dit le poète qui
a été quelqu'un de 2 à renverser les
obstacles qui a occupé les plus hautes
fonctions il ya été sous le feu des
projecteurs pendant 30 ans et qui tout
d'un coup se retrouve dans la fragilité
d'un homme malade et d'un temps qui est
un temps d'inquiétude alors c'est
évidemment très émouvant et toute sa
famille est prise dans ce maelström
madame chirac aujourd'hui et je pense
beaucoup à tautira qui fit qui traverse
toutes ces épreuves au delà des
divergences de vos divergences des
divergences ancestrale entre la droite
et le centre qu'est-ce que vous saluer
ans jacques chirac je salue deux choses
la première c'est qu'il a été
toujours soucieux de l'unité du pays
peut-être pas assez vous savez qu'il a
regretté dans un livre de ne pas avoir
suivi l'option en 2002
le pen vous l'aviez voilà il n'a pas
rassemblé c'est un peu le défi de tous
les présidents la république ce sera à
nouveau le cas en 2017 si c'est face à
ben si c'est le défi qu'il faut relever
à tout prix et donc il a écrit dans un
livre qu'il s'était trompé en ne faisant
pas ligne en nationale 1 à cet instant
mais il a constamment été soucieux de
l'unité de la société française n'a
jamais voulu entrer dans dans cette
manière d'attiser les détestations et
les rancoeurs ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose je salue ce qu'il a
fait au moment de la guerre en irak je
suis monté à la tribune contre beaucoup
de mes amis pour dire qu'ils avaient
raison de s'opposer à la guerre en irak
et je lui ai apporté un soutien sans
faille alors que beaucoup étaient
tentés on va dire les choses comme ça
par un alignement sur les américains et
ce jour là en manifestant l'indépendance
de la france il a servi l'intérêt du
pays tous les matins françois bayrou je
pose une question récurrente la question
of may devant les caméras
c'est off entre nous votre
vice-président pris le vice-président du
modem robert rochefort a été récemment
interpellées pour exhibition sexuelle
dans un magasin bricolage vous l'avez
aussitôt exclu ça fait mauvais genre non
ça prouve qu'on connaît jamais bien les
êtres humains parce que s'il ya vraiment
une personne dont j'aurai donc pas
seulement moi mais dont nul n'aurait
imaginé qu'il est ce type de fragilité
peut-être de maladie c'est bien lui
et donc voilà on connaît pas les êtres
humains c'est en alliant guingamp
c'est peu de le dire
et donc simplement j'imagine en plus
c'est une tragédie personnelle familiale
toutes ces choses est donc simplement
quand vous êtes en respect son heure
responsables politiques vous devez
prendre vos responsabilités
c'est ce que j'ai fait